blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com pakman
all right my friends so i said yesterday
we would be talking about
this today so let's just jump right into
it because it's a big topic and
and a scary one quite frankly the
question
is does it appear as though we are
barreling towards
a second violent insurrection
sometime in the month of august now
let's discuss that
first of all why are we even talking
about august we're talking about august
because the washington post and the new
york times
and the national review a conservative
leading outlet
have published articles over the last
couple of weeks outlining to different
degrees
donald trump's belief or hope that he
will be reinstated as president
of the united states sometime in august
of this year meaning in just a couple of
months
now as you know and as i know that is
impossible
you and i know that reinstatement is not
a process that is part of the american
system of government
there is a president there is a vice
president if for some reason the
president is no longer president
the vice president becomes the president
there is a line of succession
none of it includes we go back to the
previous guy
who lost an election it doesn't work
that way the next presidential election
is november of 2024 whoever wins will be
inaugurated in january of 2025 but that
doesn't matter
to donald trump and apparently it
doesn't matter to millions of his
followers around the country
who are increasingly convinced
increasingly waiting for
their fearless leader to be quote
reinstated
by the time that summer is over there
was a really good post on our subreddit
that for some reason was since
deleted by the person who posted it and
it asked potential august insurrection
is it being overlooked and the subreddit
user pointed out
they've been hearing from family in
rural missouri
they've been hearing from family in
rural wisconsin and
many of them are quote stocking up on
ammunition
and firearms for what is maybe coming in
august
they talk about trump's supposed
generals that he has on his side and
their expectation that there's going to
be an attempt
to take joe biden out of the white house
and put trump in
sometime during august and the post
pointed out
something that's pretty astute which is
that the public-facing media story has
been oh
mike flynn talking about there should be
a coup
and donald trump continuing to say the
election was stolen and we must do these
audits and trump saying i will be
president again sooner than you
think but to people thinking about that
below the surface
there is an incredibly irrational group
of people
who believe that that is a code directed
to them
that they should be ready to take up
arms against the government and sadly
in practice it may be functioning as
such a code whether that's what donald
trump intends or not it doesn't even
matter
in practice it very well may function as
a code in that sense
our viewer wrote that many of the people
that he's talking about aren't hugely
visible
online but they are quietly stocking up
ammunition
acquiring firearms and preparing to do
the worst if the time should come they
point out
that the rhetoric they are seeing on
signage in rural missouri and rural
wisconsin
has gotten crazier you know about uh
dead democrats being the only good ones
and other
violent messages so the question is
whether the possibility
of serious violence in august is being
overlooked
i believe it's important not to be
hyperbolic
i still think the most likely situation
is
when trump doesn't become president in
august
uh not much violence will happen
certainly no
big organized violent event and they'll
go and focus on november
or the next january or whatever the case
may be
that's what i think is the most likely
outcome and they'll put in place some
new arbitrary timeline
to look forward to but there is
precedent for these violent riots and
the precedent was five months ago when
on january 6th
trump riots took place in washington d.c
and we are still going through what are
now i think 450 different
uh court cases as a result so what we
can hope
is that these folks that our viewer is
seeing in missouri and wisconsin and
elsewhere number one or on the radar of
law enforcement
if you come across someone you believe
is planning to do violence
notify local law enforcement notify the
fbi the fbi is taking this seriously and
number two
for the ones that are determined to do
violence
hopefully it just won't be convenient
for them to get themselves to washington
dc
it's it's horrible to have to count on
that
but to some degree i think it will be a
factor that dissuades some of them as
well so i
share the concern with you at many times
in history even talking about
is it possible that the former president
who has continued to claim he actually
won
will lead a riot in the middle
of another president's term in order to
try to oust that president in in many
times in american history it would be
crazy to even bring this up
sadly right now um
this has changed irreversibly because of
what happened in january we now have to
take this possibility seriously
and it is a real possibility that
they may do more of it and so we're
going to continue following it
we are continuing to see what is the
totality of what we're seeing
we're seeing what donald trump is saying
of course
we are starting to see um an escalation
in the violent rhetoric from simply
republican voters
we are starting to see both online and
offline rhetoric
become more radical we are hearing from
people
coded language like we're going to get
the white house back
sooner than you think when it's like
well you could get it back in november
of 2024 that's the soonest
but they're they're going beyond that in
the way that they're hinting and
fainting so
that's f-e-i-n-t uh so unfortunately
i share this concern i hope that there
is no violence in august but i worry
that something is building here and if
so
i do hope law enforcement is aware of it
speaking of violence we haven't done
this for a while
and and i think it's important to do it
again
did you know that there were 10 mass
shootings this past weekend
just this past weekend that finished a
couple days ago
the gun violence archive tracks mass
shootings
and on june 4th 5th and 6th there were
10
individual shooting incidents in which a
minimum
of four victims were shot
either injured or killed not including
any shooter who may have also been
injured or killed
during the incident this is ten
incidents
where at least four people were killed
and or
injured and consider for a second by
this definition of mass shooting where
you need at least
four injuries or deaths there were a
whole bunch of other incidents with
two or three people being injured and
killed
when the baseline is set at four
injured and killed we had 10
such incidents this past weekend and it
barely made news
it is just another normal weekend in the
united states of america
some examples in portland oregon four
were killed
and one were injured at a home in
indianapolis indiana
two were killed and two were injured all
in the parking lot
of a boston market restaurant in north
carolina
four people were shot and injured at a
party
at a trailer park and i could go through
and give you
all of the various stories but you can
imagine
how all of these or many of these went
down
but 10 mass shootings this weekend and
it barely makes news
because it has become background noise
that's the tragic reality of the
situation
the the loss of life the injury that's
one tragedy
the other tragedy is that this stuff
barely even makes the news anymore ah
another weekend
another 10 mass shootings and the number
is probably more like 25 if you include
those where
two or three people were injured as well
also
it's embarrassing it's not just tragic
it's embarrassing the world
looks at us clearly we have the
resources for dealing with this
it's not a money issue we have no
shortage of ideas for how to deal with
it even if you know without touching the
second amendment which we have a second
amendment okay
without even going close to infringing
on the second amendment
we have so many ideas for things that
should be done look at what happened on
vaccines
once we got competent leadership in
power in january we clearly can do
things
we clearly can manage big projects
there's no it's not an impossibility
and yet there is simply no political
will
to deal with this and it's a global
embarrassment truly
and you know even if you don't care
about gun violence per se
like maybe you don't do you realize how
this makes us look to our adversaries
and the ideas that this gives our
adversaries they
see another weekend another 10 mass
shootings what the hell is wrong with
these americans
if the u they are saying if the u.s
population has been propagandized enough
that they won't do anything on guns if
they can't even pass
100 universal background checks uh
when when democrats control the house
senate white house and right after this
the sandy hook shooting if they can't do
that clearly these are very
manipulatable people
this is one of those situations where
the world sees the insanity of this
is this not yet affecting the right
people
and that's why nothing is being done is
the combination
of the gun profit lobby because that's
what they are and the gun nuts is that
combination too powerful
to allow anything to be done my issue
isn't even with the firearms
necessarily but it's with american gun
culture
lack of screening lack of enforcement of
laws
lack of of ongoing training
insurance policies if you own guns lack
of access to mental health
treatment the political movement that
fetishizes guns yeah okay the guns are a
problem but what i mean is
it doesn't have to be a problem of guns
necessarily
and i'm being careful with the wording
here in our case it is a problem of guns
but also of all of those other things
that i mentioned
and the world sees it and it's
humiliating it's tragic
it's embarrassing and there is no i mean
i wish i had any optimism
i i have no optimism you know okay biden
announced some stuff they're gonna be
he is directing the creation of certain
groups to look at okay
it was an effort but most of that is
just hey please look into this type
stuff
i am not optimistic on this issue at all
if you are
let me know why let me know why i should
be more optimistic you can find me on
twitter
at deepakman
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
all right so this you have to see um as
if things couldn't get any worse for
rudy giuliani he has now been completely
exposed by some newly released audio
recordings
in which he just straight up calls
ukraine and says hey
here's what we need you to say about
investigating joe biden and this goes
back of course to donald trump's
supposedly perfect phone call with
ukraine
and the entire impeachment fiasco rudy's
house has been searched
rudy's office has been searched rudy
farted multiple times during that
bogus bogus voter fraud hearing in
michigan or who knows where that one was
rudy represented the most pathetic
failure of a president in the modern
political era and
now caught on audio recordings it just
won't
stop this is new content and rudy is
potentially in some
really serious trouble here so let's
listen to the first clip
there's something notable here there's
an important detail which is actually a
theme of these clips which we suspected
before
so see if you can spot it on this first
time through
and what we need all we need for the
present is to say
i'm going to put an honest prosecutor in
charge he's going to investigate
and dig up the evidence
that presently exists and is there any
other evidence
about involvement of the 2016 election
and then the buying thing has to be run
out
i don't know if it's true or not i mean
i i see
i see him bragging about it on
television
and to me as a warrior to me as a lawyer
he sounds like a bride did you notice
that rudy keeps saying
we need him to say we are investigating
biden
this is not rudy wanting justice done
he doesn't actually say we need the
investigation to be done
he insists that they need the
investigation
announced and we had a sense that this
was the case
from what we knew before remember our
understanding before we didn't have
recordings
but our understanding before was they
were asking for
the announcement of an investigation
they didn't really care about the
investigation itself because they wanted
the propaganda value to say look
ukraine has just announced an
investigation whether it took place or
not
it didn't even really matter it wasn't
about proving joe biden did anything or
hunter biden did anything it was about
claiming
they are doing an investigation period
joe biden is
under investigation is what they wanted
from a propaganda perspective
and there's more of that phraseology in
this next segment let's check it out and
listen to the exact same thing if he
could make some statement
at the right time that he supports a
fair honest law enforcement system and
that these investigations
go wherever they have to go gonna be run
by honest people
that would clear the air uh really well
so there it is again
if he could make some statements at the
right time
justice has no right time rudy come on
but rudy doesn't care about justice and
rudy doesn't care about finding out what
happened that's not what this was about
this was rudy and trump deciding we want
an announcement that there's an
investigation into joe biden
at a time that is politically suitable
meaning
suitable for trump in trying to get
himself re-elected
against who he imagined would be his
opponent joe biden
let's listen to the last bit here and
and here you actually get the offer of
the quid pro quo
it's it's stunning that it's all on tape
guys
we have the recordings now here is the
quid pro quo offer
and i think it would make it possible
for me to
come and make it possible i think for me
to talk to the president and
see what i can do about making sure that
whatever
misunderstandings are put aside and
maybe even
i kind of think that this is this could
be a good thing for
having a much a much better relationship
where we really understand each other
so there's the closing of the circle on
the quid pro quo
if you announce these investigations
into joe biden not even if you do them
if you announce the investigations into
joe biden
then i can talk to trump and we can
resolve all of those
misunderstandings this is gangster code
this is mafia code right this is
you never fully say it but you say hey
uh you know our problem
i think if you were able to cut me in
as a partner on this business which
means give me some money so i don't rip
your
you know whatever off uh if if you could
make me a partner
in this in this uh enterprise i think
i'd be able to go and talk to you know
who and we could really come to an
understanding about what's
whoa what what are you talking about
that is the language that rudy is using
here we could resolve the
misunderstanding by me talking to trump
i'll talk to trump and
it's all going to be resolved meaning i
will get the messages
you want over to trump and we can deal
with sanctions we can get you the
military aid
whatever you want our problems we're
going to be able to solve them
if these investigations are announced
into joe biden it's almost identical to
i need you to do us a favor though
i need you from the perfect phone call i
need you to do us a favor though
they were working for that favor among
multiple angles
and we now have the latest bit of it
which is rudy on tape
asking for it when does it become
treason
for the personal lawyer to the president
of the united states
then sitting president to offer favors
to other countries in exchange for
favorable public announcements to help
that sitting president
in his ongoing uh re-election campaign
at some point
don't we have to start using that term
stunning and disgusting stuff doesn't
look good for rudy
donald trump is continuing his media
tour meanwhile and he somehow ended up
on the stuart varney show on the fox
business channel fox business is like
the lower rated
counterpart to fox news stuart varney is
i won't even say much about him stuart
varney is a guy who in this interview
allows donald trump to just say whatever
the hell he wants even obvious lies and
get away with it with no pushback and
stuart varney
you know he loves bringing on richard
wolff economist richard wolf friend of
our show my former professor
varney will bring on richard wolff and
argue with him if if wolf says the sky
is blue
stewart varney's going to argue with him
and trump comes in
and he talks about ballot dumps from
mark zuckerberg he talks about how he
won the election
uh and here is a brilliant idea from
trump during this interview
you want to stop cyber attacks stuart
stop using computers
hell trump has no idea how to use one do
we even really need
computers this is the suggestion of the
former president take a look well
that's here to stay according to the
commerce secretary how do we stop it
i mean the commerce says
form of accounting and things you know
i have a son who's so good with
computers he's a young
person and i mean he can make these
things sing and when you
put everything on internet and on all
of these machines you never see a piece
of paper
i really think you have to go back to a
different form of
of uh accounting a different form of
compiling information because anybody
can break in i mean i see
young people they can't walk without
computers that what they can do with
them is
incredible i'm witness to it because as
a young
as a young person my 15 year old son
is you know he's just a genius with this
stuff
and and you have you have people that
are going to break into systems i think
you have to go back and
you have to be much more reliant they
have to be has to be much better
security
and the kind of information i think is
mind-boggling
he simply can't avoid mentioning
that baron knows how to use computers
anytime he talks about cyber attacks
trump
is such a luddite when it comes to
computers
that he's always if computers are
mentioned you should see what my 15 year
old son is doing with them but
listen to the suggestion how do you deal
with cyber threats
just get everything off the internet
stop using computers he
sounds like an out of touch old guy who
just refuses to accept
modern technology it's it's stunning and
stuart varney just accepts it he says
well that would take some time
but he's basically accepting it how is
that a solution anybody could take
seriously even for a second
then trump's move on moves on trump
moves on
to pushing the completely baseless
conspiracy theory
that u.s coveted cases and deaths were
falsely over
counted to make him look bad
we're going back to may of 2020 my
friends the truth is the opposite cases
and deaths are undercounted and we'll
talk about that in a moment but
here is trump stuart varney like a
doormat he offers no pushback whatsoever
things we are in a position a lot of
people that have had
coveted and you know i think you had
reported numbers far greater than the
actual numbers
uh a person that i know just told me his
father died i said oh that's too bad
what happened it was a heart attack
but they put down kovid i said what do
you mean it was hard did he have covert
no
he didn't have covert they put down cove
but so many
so many deaths are reported this whole
thing is
whether it was election fraud or other
frauds
but you know there are many many more
cases than if you take a look and i'm
sure you've heard this you're
a professional to put it mildly but
this was just an interesting
conversation i had with somebody
that i frankly that i barely know
and uh they said it was coveted but i've
heard that many times before
many many times before is it over in
america
now so there it is uh somebody trump
barely knows
mentioned this to him this is a
how many times has this been debunked
this goes back to may of 2020
we are under counting we are under
counting
covet cases and deaths first of all
before testing was ramped up
there were tons of cases my girlfriend
and i think
we may have had this when we were in
europe very very early in 2020 there was
no testing
so there are likely hundreds of
thousands if not millions of cases that
were never captured because there wasn't
enough testing at one point in time
then asymptomatic cases there were
tons of asymptomatic cases which still
could have been transmitting
people never thought to go and get a
test there were lots of people
who had cold like or flu-like symptoms
and just
didn't feel sick enough to even go and
get treatment or or
seek medical advice they were never
tested the real number of coveted cases
in the u.s is likely two to three times
the official rate and then as far as
deaths go there were
many deaths we know particularly early
on no autopsies were done
there was no posthumous coveted testing
there were people who died
at home who were never tested so the
real numbers
are much higher than the official
numbers not lower but
varney doesn't care he's going to let
trump say whatever he wants
and then now here is the really big lie
that donald trump won in 2020
no pushback from stuart varney and trump
raises stuff now about
lock boxes with dumps ballot dumps that
is
uh trump's a weird guy but he meant
ballot dumps um controlled by mark
zuckerberg of facebook
it's all crazy take a look at this
powerful i got 75 million votes which is
more than any sitting president
ever got i won the election but they
cheated
and by the way facebook and zuckerberg
with a 500 million dollars worth of
phony lock boxes
that he put on some of them had 96 biden
votes in them 96
they were like just dumping ballots it
was a phony deal
so that's new to me i hadn't heard that
before phony
zuckerberg facebook lock boxes
with ballot dumps inside of them it's
something else
and it is it's just out of this world
disconnected
from reality and varney just watches it
all he has nothing to say about it
at some point it would be amazing if one
of these
fox hosts or newsmax or whoever if they
had the guts to simply say
mr president sir you
will not stop spreading corrosive lies
you incited the january 6 riots you seem
desperate to do it again not on my show
mr president what would happen if a fox
reporter did that
they'd probably be fired but wouldn't it
be worth it
it would be seen as heroic not just by
much of the united states but by most of
the world it would go giga-viral
instantly it would if someone really let
trump have it during one of these
interviews instead stewart varney
is like a clock on the wall just silent
he's like a doormat trump's walking all
over him i get it varney has producers
he wants his job he was told do the
interview in this way
okay i'm not saying that this was
exactly the right
moment and i'm not saying that there
wouldn't have been consequences but
if someone like varney had the guts to
just do it
say mr president this ends today you
will stop spreading these corrosive lies
that led to that violent insurrection
you lost and you can't admit it
uh if it were actually live and you know
that it would get out there
that would really be something else i
encourage any one of these reporters to
think about it think about what you're
doing for your legacy
by allowing trump to do what he did to
stuart varney
versus what you could actually do if you
stand up to him and have the guts to do
it just just a thought
just a thought make sure you're
subscribed to our
new youtube channel we have a completely
separate youtube channel pacmanlive you
can find it at davidpakman.com
slash pacman live uh clips from the live
streams if you don't often
catch the live streams we're taking the
best pieces
the best elements of the live streams
and putting them on the second youtube
channel
we are heading towards our first 5 000
subscribers
and you can find it at
davidpakman.compacmanlive
and for more on the varney interview
make sure you're following us on
instagram davidpakmanshow on all one
word on instagram we'll take a quick
break i will be speaking with professor
olivier saboni coming up next a very
interesting conversation i'm sure and
then
much more after that
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a
member which gives you access to the
daily bonus show
the regular show with no commercials you
also get access to our entire archive
of every episode dating back a really
long time
and plenty of other awesome membership
perks go to joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21
for a huge discount join pacman.com
it is my pleasure today to welcome to
the program
professor olivier siboni at hec
paris as well as co-author of the book
noise a flaw in human judgment
co-written by daniel kahneman as well as
cass sunstein cass a a multi-time guest
on the program before
uh olivier so great to have you on today
thanks for having me so maybe to start
with to kind of introduce some of the
things we're we're talking about
many of us can imagine situations uh in
which the
inputs seem to be the same it might be a
situation where a patient
goes to two different doctors with the
same symptoms or
a driver is driving and there is a
situation with some pedestrians and
vehicles where
the circumstances seem to be the same
but there's
something we call human judgment that is
applied which sometimes gets each
individual to make a different decision
whether it's driving whether it's about
a diagnostic
test that a doctor wants to do in in
your world how do you start
quantifying this x factor of human
judgment and thinking about it in a way
that we can start
making some observations about it let's
first start
by double clicking on what you call
human judgment here
because in the examples you've taken yes
we have human judgment
in some cases we also have human
judgment but we don't
mind variation so say we are deciding
you know what what hotel we prefer in a
foreign city
or or what dish we prefer in the menu
it's fine if you and i disagree right
that's not something where we
where we expect uniformity the the
problem that we've been
writing about in noise is when we have
human judgment on which we expect
uniformity on which we think there is a
correct
answer for instance as you said when a
patient is visiting a doctor
the diagnosis should not be a matter of
opinion it should not be a matter of
taste or preference it should be
a matter of professional judgment and we
pretty much expect that different
doctors would come to the same judgment
and the problem is quite often they
don't
and that's what we call noise the
unwanted variability in human judgment
what are the factors that we what are
the categories of factors that can
create these
differences you know i remember reading
about in fact it may have been a daniel
kahneman book now i don't remember
offhand
about sentencing in criminal cases
and how one factor that affected
sentencing was
is it close to lunchtime or is it after
lunch time in other words how hungry is
the judge
seemed to play a role in determining a
sentence what
what category would that type of of
a judgment discrepancy fall
under and what types of categories are
there so this category
the example you take here which is a
famous study of judicial decisions
is what we call occasion noise occasion
noise is the fact that
the same people looking at the same
facts
on two different occasions will
sometimes not have exactly the same
judgment so
a judge looking at the same defendant
try it for the same case
before lunch or after lunch will not
have exactly the same judgment and by
the way
this is true also of factors such as the
temperature
whether the weather is sunny or rainy
whether the judge's favorite football
team
won or lost the game the previous day
and whether the previous cases that the
judge looked at
were favorable or unfavorable so there
are a lot of factors that are going to
influence a judge that are completely
extraneous to the case that should have
nothing to do with the case but
influence it
that's what we call occasion noise it's
variation
within the person and we can all feel
this
when we when we know oh i made that
decision because i was in a bad mood if
i think back on it
i would have made a different decision
now that i'm in a good mood right that's
that's fairly intuitive we're aware of
that we probably underestimate it but
we're
aware of it that's one of the categories
uh can you give us some of the other
other categories sure so another
category which is
relatively easy to wrap your mind around
is if you take again the example of
judges that people have different
average levels of severity so some
judges are going to be tough hanging
judges
other judges are going to be more
lenient they are you know the bleeding
hard judges who feel for the defendant
if you give these two judges the same 20
different cases
of course each of the 20 cases is
different but the average sentence
that the bleeding heart judge gives is
going to be a lot less than the average
sentence and the heart judge gives
that's what we call level noise and then
there is a third category
which is a bit harder to wrap your mind
around but which is
actually the most important one and it's
easy to
to see if you think again of the judges
take these two judges the linear one
and the and the tough one not only do
they disagree
on the average level of their sentences
they're also going to disagree on each
case
if you ask them to rank the cases from
the the worst case to the least severely
punishable case
they are not going to agree on the
ranking because basically they have
different tastes
they are different individuals they have
different life experiences
they have different preferences they may
have different political
opinions basically they see different
things in the cases that they look at
they have different patterns of judgment
and that's what we call pattern noise so
we have
occasion noise we have level noise we
have pattern noise
when you put all those things together
you have a lot of reasons
for judgments that should be identical
ideally
to in fact differ and differ quite a bit
so there are people who are maybe
technocratic by nature who when you
present this to them
they would come up with a solution maybe
when it comes to the sentencing question
or maybe when it comes to
um when a patient comes in with certain
complaints what's the path of testing
that that should be done
where they would essentially say we need
to eliminate
some of this variability we will use a
computer program of some kind
artificial intelligence we put in the
inputs and it tells us this person
should get seven
years in prison and everybody gets seven
years in prison or
this patient should get the cat scan
this one should not that would be one
approach to this
is that does that account for
the true nature of complexity
with many of these situations or would
that solution leave something
out that's important well there is a
difficult tradeoff to make here
what is guaranteed is that if you do
what you just described
you will eliminate the noise yes because
whatever system whatever rule whatever
algorithm whatever
formula you put in place is going to be
noise free and that's why
it's often when you actually measure the
performance of
algorithms and rules and so on it's
often quite good
because it eliminates the noise the
level noise the occasion noise the
pattern knows it basically makes sure
that when you have the same inputs you
will have the same output
now does that make does that necessarily
make rules and algorithms a good thing
no because noise is not the only way you
can be wrong you can also have bias
so suppose to take an extreme but not
completely crazy case
that you have a rule that says anyone
who's been sentenced
of this particular crime gets exactly
this punishment
or anyone who's been sentenced three
times of a felony
goes to jail for life three three
strikes and you're out
yes well you've eliminated noise there
at least if you apply the rule
but a lot of people would say you've
created another form of error which is a
form of bias
which is that you are giving too
severe a sentence to a lot of people who
would not deserve that sentence
yes you've eliminated the unwanted
variability between people who have
committed the same three crimes
but you've added a lot of bias in the
form of unwanted severity
against people who have committed three
not so bad crimes
so there's a trade-off between how
accurate
and how unbiased an algorithm or rule
can be
and the fact that it will be noise-free
because that trade-off is a difficult
one there's going to be lots of cases
where
in fact you will have to continue to
resort to human judgment you cannot
replace it with a rule
and therefore you need to try to make it
better less noisy without eliminating
the human component
where where biases affect human judgment
sometimes it has been argued that
being aware of these biases can help
mitigate their impact so whether it's
availability bias or whether it's
confirmation bias that understanding
that this is something that might impact
our judgment helps us to reduce it when
it comes to
noise is is awareness also useful
in mitigating it in an individual or is
it less useful
so first of all for bias there isn't
actually a lot of evidence that simply
being aware of biases
is an effective lasting sustainable way
to reduce your biases
it doesn't work that well awareness is
good right it makes you more
careful but it's not in itself
sufficient
for noise it's even worse okay because
here's the problem of noise
you don't know which way it's going to
make you go wrong you don't know of
all the possible sources of noise of
everything that affects you in a
particular occasion
or full your individual preferences that
could be different from somebody else's
of all the factors that can influence
you on a particular case
you don't know in what direction it's
going to make you go wrong so you need
to actually take
a stance that we call decision hygiene
that is a form of prevention against
noise without knowing how noise is going
to affect you
the reason we call it decision hygiene
uh which is slightly off-putting and
that's intentional
is that we we liken this to
washing your hands when you wash your
hands
you don't know what germs you're
eliminating you you're not saying oh
this is the covid virus and this is the
flu virus and have you know
these two particular things right and in
fact if you're successful you will never
know what problem you've prevented
but you know that it's good discipline
that it's good practice that it's good
hygiene likewise everything that you do
in your decision making process
ahead of the decision ahead of time to
make your decision process
more disciplined is going to improve the
quality of your decisions because it's
going to make you less noisy when it
comes to institutions versus individuals
noise at the institutional level
sometimes can lead
to what what some call systemic types of
biases you could imagine how
noise and human judgment might lead to
racial discrimination in housing
decisions for example
or transportation decisions about
where should the stops for the subway
line be which could be influenced by all
all of these types of factors do you
approach
institutional decision making noise
differently than for example
a doctor or a driver making a decision
about an individual patient for example
we actually view the doctor as part of
an institution okay when you only see
one doctor
you will never know if your doctor is
noisy you go to your doctor your doctor
tells you you have the flu you go home
you
take your medicine and it gets better or
it doesn't get better you will never
know
whether another doctor in the same
hospital would have told you no it's not
the fluids cause it 19
right or it's not the flu it's something
else so
if you think about who should take care
of noise
it's actually always the institution as
individuals we can try to make ourselves
more disciplined
but the institution whether it's the
hospital the justice system
the uh you know the the organization
that takes care of hiring individuals
or the the company that has a hiring
process
all those institutions should try to
reduce
both the noise and the biases in their
decisions and if they put in place good
decision hygiene practices they will
reduce noise they will also at the same
time reduce the sorts of systemic biases
that you're talking about because when
you put in place
good decision practices you will make
your decisions less
exposed less dependent less sensitive to
the biases of individuals
the last thing i wanted to talk about is
where there are some cases where
where maybe both noise and bias
are good in the sense that they are sort
of what makes us uniquely
human and the example that i will give
is as we learn more about autonomous
vehicles
and the decisions that drivers are
sometimes making
almost intuitively in a fraction of a
second about for example
merging in a rotary or traffic circle
whether it's the right time or it's not
the right time
or about getting through a yellow light
or not this is something that
it's really been reduced to it's it's
happening in a very very small amount of
time
and we're sort of intuitively
considering the position of pedestrians
and how far we are from the light
in some of these cases there will be
variability
but it seems that that it's actually
quite hard
to replicate it accurately with an
artificial intelligence or or with
computers what about those cases where
noise seems to be a sort of uniquely
human ability to make these judgment
calls in a very small amount of time
so we wouldn't call this noise we would
say that those
quick decisions that you're talking
about are system one decisions they are
decisions that are made without
consciously thinking about what you're
doing and that are based on a lot of
learning that has taken place
they can be excellent decisions that you
can have great
instincts if you have been well trained
you can have acquired
expertise at something so if you are a
formula one driver
your your instincts to drive a formula
one car
are extraordinarily fine extraordinarily
fine-tuned and you're able to make
you know decisions in a fraction of a
second that
quite likely would be difficult for a
computer to make
now is this a case of noise we wouldn't
call this a case of noise in the sense
that those decisions are
hypothetically as you as you describe
them good they're actually consistent
the the the expert would make the same
decision a lot of times when faced with
the same situation
where we would see noise is when
a person making a decision is not
consistent and different people are not
consistent with each other in the
decisions that they make
and that creates variability that is not
the case in the example you were talking
about where
presumably there there may be humans who
are better than machines and that will
remain the case for
a long time in a lot of important
decisions so those it's it's really a
different category altogether
yes um and and there will be you know we
i i don't want to give the impression
that that machines are the solution to
everything and and clearly they aren't
and that's why we're writing this book
that actually talks not about how to
eliminate human judgment but how to
replace it
there will be lots of decisions that we
will want humans to make either because
it's too difficult to
have a machine that makes it or because
we don't want
the machine to make it in our place
because we we care about dealing with
a different human being we want to give
people a sense of
agency we want to give people who
interact with the decision the dignity
of dealing with the human being and not
with the machine
there are lots of very valid reasons to
retain human judgment
and when that is the case we need to
make sure that those judgments
if they cannot be the sort of expert
snap second judgments that you are
talking about
that they are made in a considered
careful way so that they are less noisy
more just
and less prone to error that uh that
that makes a lot of sense
uh we've been speaking about the book
noise of flying human judgment
co-written
by daniel kahneman cass sunstein and our
guest today professor olivier ciboni
uh so great having you on i really
appreciate your time today
thank you very much david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos
the daily bonus show the commercial free
daily show
as well as special discounts on merch
including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts
you can support the show for as little
as
two dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com
david pakman show so i was not um
initially inclined to talk about what's
going on with uh milo yiannopoulos
uh who is now saying he is no longer gay
he's now heterosexual
i i wasn't initially going to talk about
it but it's getting enough attention
and i personally had an interaction with
milo a couple of weeks ago and so i do
want to talk a little bit about it today
now if you're not familiar with milo
yiannopoulos he's a right-wing sort of
provocateur
who for a long time got plenty of
attention because he was
a gay conservative and he liked to say
that because he's a gay conservative the
left can't say all the things about him
that they would normally say about
heterosexual conservatives who are about
so-called family values and conservative
beliefs and on and
on but ultimately milo fell out of favor
with the american right wing
he supported donald trump you know he
did all the things that are the right
things that he
should have been doing but he fell out
of favor with them because some videos
came to light in which milo expressed
views about sex with underage
people that i won't repeat here but the
the comments were concerning even for
people on the right
who previously supported milo
yiannopoulos so milo sort of disappeared
and there were pieces written about him
about how he lost his career
and he lost his income and all of these
things and then milo reappeared
not long ago saying he has left
homosexuality
and he has fixed his life and has had
quite literally a sort of come to jesus
moment
now the exact wording around this
has to be looked at closely i don't know
if milo is being consistent in terms of
is he is he no longer attracted to men
or does he simply choose to no longer be
romantically
involved with men but he has the
attractions with all of this quitting
homosexuality stuff
these questions are always there and the
answers are rarely satisfactory i don't
know
and quite frankly it doesn't matter
because that aspect of the ex-gay thing
i'm pretty sick of but i'm gonna play a
clip where milo showed up on true news
not a program i'm familiar with that's
tru true news and
he said that as soon as he became ex-gay
dogs stopped barking at him which he
believes is a sign
from god let's take a look when i made
my announcement
the first thing that happened which will
make you laugh but it's true is
dogs stopped barking at me i am one of
those people you know everyone's got
that friend that dogs always go nuts
around
are you familiar with this right you got
pets yes yeah right there's always
somebody that dogs
my dog
this sounds so stupid but this is just
how i think
that god reveals himself to us right
this is this is just
my experience of it i was somebody who
invariably
without exception always used to make
dogs go crazy
so we have a friend who's a political
candidate down here right and her
campaign manager has two of these little
yappy dogs and they would not stop i
couldn't be in her house for more than
20 minutes because it would drive
everybody crazy
even growing up we had alsatians we had
black labradors
um they just didn't like me at all
but dogs don't bark at me anymore and it
happened almost overnight now they seem
to quite like me and that sounds it's
the stupidest thing in the world
so there there's a lot there and i don't
know if other people have noticed this
but there's this thing
where when you're on a show like this
where i guess the hosts are devout
christians or whatever
no matter how one says god revealed
himself to them
no matter how stupid or bizarre they
always accept it
and they nod and they say yeah yeah milo
says you know
this might sound stupid but i believe
god revealed himself to me and is
sending me the message that i was right
to quit homosexuality
by making dogs no longer bark at me oh
that's great that's
you know god god reveals himself to us
in different ways
actually that's idiotic that's
absolutely ridiculous why would god
communicate in that way it makes no
sense oh well but god works in
mysterious ways
like through dog barks oh okay well then
i guess that we can't touch that
that uh it's an unassailable comment
then now my real comment
my real concern here is two different
things
first of all the damage that this ex-gay
quitting homosexuality stuff can do to
young
lgbt individuals who might see this or
hear about
milo quit being gay as if it's like a
hobby
and thinking that that's something they
could do or something that they should
do
everything we know is that not living as
oneself
is not a good thing emotionally and
seeing this
might plant the idea in other people's
minds that this is this is something to
be
pursued or even to be applauded to to um
what what milo is doing when it's not
the second concern is remember
milo was pulled out of the public eye
after being shamed for his comments
about sex with underage kids
this entire thing to me seems like an
attempt to link homosexuality with
pedophilia
and that's why all these shows are
having milo on to cheerlead what he's
doing because remember here
what's the framing the framing is milo
used to be gay and he was gay when he
said this stuff
about sex with underage kids now he
found god
now he's heterosexual and so now it
helps to
distance himself from those things he
said it's an
a pathetic attempt to link homosexuality
in pedophilia which is another old
homophobic trope
so i invited milo to come on the show to
talk about all this
i said you're welcome to come on i would
love to speak with you about this recent
announcement
and he wrote me back and he simply
declined he said he's not interested in
that
and based on the shows i've seen him do
lately it seems he's interested in
the type of interview he got on true
news that's fine
that that's fine this is not me on a
power trip saying how dare he
decline being on my program when we are
so much bigger than true news
i it's i understand why he said no to
this show he would actually have to
answer or at least
be asked he wouldn't have to answer it
would be up to him he would actually be
asked real questions on this program and
to me this seems more than anything else
an attempt
to regain relevance and get attention
once and again the invitation to milo
remains open
welcome on the program anytime hey this
i don't want to spend a lot of time on
this
it's it's quite dense it's worth reading
on your own
but propublica did a really interesting
study of the richest americans
and what they looked at is how much in
taxes
the richest americans paid relative to
how much their wealth grew during the
same time period now
a lot of this has to do with unrealized
gains and i'm going to explain that in a
moment but this is one of the ways in
which the rich
really benefit the super super super
rich i'm not talking about people who
make
500k a year here talking about the super
super rich
in the united states when you have an
increase in net worth this could be
because you earned money
by working or you might have an increase
in net worth because
assets you hold increased in value if
you hold a bunch of stocks a million
dollars in stocks and they go up and
they're worth two million dollars in
stocks
your net worth just went up by a million
dollars you don't owe any taxes
other than on the dividends depending on
what type of account those funds or
stocks are held in right so but
the gist of it is you don't owe any
taxes on that gain of a million dollars
in net worth
until you realize the gain by selling
those
stocks so what you've seen over the last
uh from 2014 to 2018
is that the 25 richest americans saw
their collective
net worth go up by 400 billion dollars
but they only paid 13.6 billion dollars
in federal income taxes so that is a 3.4
percent
now i know many people are going to say
david david hold on
uh they didn't have a taxable event a
lot of that growth and net worth came
from
they held assets and the assets went up
in value if i have a
two million dollar house and the market
explodes and it's worth four million
my net worth went up two million dollars
i don't owe any taxes on that
okay my real estate taxes might go up a
little if the assessment goes up right
there's some details
that's how it works david i understand
but the analysis is an interesting one
nonetheless which is
when you were already very wealthy you
were able to
increase your net worth with very little
tax exposure for the average person if
you make
50 000 a year and you get a raise to 75
000
a year that's a nice raise that increase
in the net worth you could have
by saving your additional salary is
going to be dragged down by the fact
that you're paying income taxes on that
additional salary so the the
investigation
is an interesting one because it exposes
the
tax on net worth growth which is really
really low now am i proposing a
particular change in policy as a result
of this no i have other segments on that
but it's a very interesting way to look
at how by not realizing gains
and by having assets that grow
that are disproportionately already held
by the very rich you can have
a net worth grow with extremely low
drag from taxes tax drag as it is often
called
and it is another one of the ways in
which just increasing income taxes which
is often what the discussion is it's
what we're talking about now with joe
biden
does very very little to actually
capture the vast majority of the benefit
to the ultra ultra ultra rich we're
talking about multi-billionaires here
this is a very different thing
than someone with a small business like
joe the plumbers which supposedly made
250 000 a year but didn't actually
very very different situation we have a
voicemail number that number is
2192davidp
here's a really good question about
vaccination via voicemail listen to this
hey david i was calling because my
mother is a trumper
and i am a democrat i have been
vaccinated my mother refuses to get it
and my question for you is do you think
that if trump would have won the
presidency again and had the opportunity
to be on the big stage to brag about it
being
trump's vaccine yep do you think more
republicans
would have been likely to get the
vaccine of course
of course it is undeniable if trump had
won
and had figured out how to distribute
the vaccine the way joe biden did
and was presiding over what we are now
seeing with the virus
you would see way more republicans go
and get themselves vaccinated the most
anti-covet vaccine group is trump
supporters
if trump had said if trump had won and
then when he got vaccinated in secret on
january whatever
trump had announced it and done it
publicly and continued talking about the
vaccine i did it i brought you the
vaccine
way more trumpus would have been
vaccinated that doesn't mean that we
would be better off with trump overall
but there is no doubt whatsoever
excellent excellent question you are
completely right
we have a great voicemail i'm sorry we
have a great bonus show today we will
talk about the u.s recovering millions
in the crypto
ransom that was paid to colonial by
colonial pipeline
the fbi was able to recover a bunch of
it very interesting
republicans are also pledging allegiance
to fossil fuels
again and the supreme court has ruled
against immigrants
who are in temporary status seeking
green cards right now not a good ruling
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
i will see you then if you are a david
pakman show member
sign up at joinpackman.com and remember
to subscribe
free to the new youtube channel you can
find it at davidpakman.com
pacman live
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25
percent off a subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman